sinon le rapport de l'âme du sens un
petit handicap est un petit peu de gras
un petit peu d'acidité tomates mixer et
confit d'oignons rouges
un apéritif validé par le responsable du
pôle audit et labellisation de gault et
millau
depuis décembre le chef cuisinier de
l'établissement courrier en ville à
saint-antoine aux chaînés rocancourt a
reçu le label du célèbre guide
gastronomique
il propose aux résidents des plats faits
sur place avec des produits frais nous
nos résidents ils sont pour nous ils
sont comme au restaurant tous les jours
faut avoir l'oreille l'écoutent du du
résident pour nous c'est des clients
pour obtenir la labellisation une visite
d'un inspecteur de gault et millau a
lieu dans l'établissement durant toute
une journée il goûte chaque plat texture
normale et mixez la cuisine pour une
grosse partie de la note le service
l'accueil la bienveillance sont des
critères tous ces critères mélanger
audités noté produisent
un bilan final qui permet à
l'établissement des clubs lisez ou non
aujourd'hui au menu du jour pâté en
entrée docks de boeuf à la provençale et
crème pâtissière les résidents au
courant de cette labellisation ont des
avis différents
c'est trop copieux vaudrait mieux que ce
soit moins copieux est meilleur c'est
varié c'est un bon cuisinier je retrouve
vraiment les saveurs d'avant parce que
si vous voulez gault et millau est
passée par là et moi toute ma jeunesse
j'étais abonnée à gault et millau
l'obtention de ce label valorise le
travail de l'équipe en cuisine c'est une
fierté pour la directrice de
l'établissement et gault et millau c'est
surtout laventure d'une équipe le
souhait d'évoluer le souhait de grandir
dans du haut de gamme et de proposer à
nos résidents une prestation de haute
qualité
gault et millau a labellisé depuis 2007
plus de 80 ehpad korian dont un second
établissement dans les yvelines
la maison de retraite les saules à
guyancourt